[Musique]
on se remet dalmon soir messieurs là
vous devez vous demandez et vous devez
vous dire que ça commence plutôt mal
surtout ne doutez pas de vous un plus un
en mathématiques font bien deux je vais
vous expliquer comment je suis arrivé à
ce résultat est à cette équation en
mettant de côté l'arithmétique et en se
focalisant davantage sur la biologie
je m'appelle xavier bailly je travaille
dans un institut de biologie marine à la
station biologique de roscoff pas loin
d'ici
pour illustrer mes propos je suis venu
avec mon animal favori qui est un petit
peu devenu un animal de compagnie ces
quinze dernières années parce que c'est
un objet d'étude et mon objet de
recherche également alors c'est un petit
ver marin qui s'appelle roscoff et 6
passes et son nom latin pour faire plus
simple on va l'appeler le vert de
roscoff
vous trouverez sur tout le littoral
atlantique principalement sur des plages
sableuses et puis sur les plages de
bretagne si vous observez bien par
exemple ces motifs verts et même d'un
peu plus près voilà ce que vous pouvez y
voir une multitude de petits verres
verts qui se déplace en colonie à des
millions d'individus à la surface du
sable dans les écoulements d'eau de mer
ou dans des flaques et ceux à marée
basse déclama dès que la marée remonte
l'ensemble de la colonie se réfugie dans
le sable et il reste tout le temps de
marée haute
dès que la marée redescend toute la
colonie réapparaît à la surface du sable
et ainsi de suite
au rythme des marées un mouvement
vertical sur le sable quand la marée est
basse dans le sable quand la marée haute
vous avez probablement remarqué sa
couleur verte assez caractéristique
d'ailleurs de nombreux hauts logist
quand ils sont commencé à décrire et à
se pencher sur ce verre ont été
intrigués par cette couleur son origine
sa nature et si on regarde un petit peu
mieux
sept photos prises au microscope d'un
jeune vert de roscoff
on voit un ensemble de petites cellules
verte répartis de façon homogène dans
les tissus j'ai bien dit dans les tissus
à l'intérieur des tissus
ce sont des micro algues alors ces
microalgues elles sont capables date
elles ont les atteigne un nombre pardon
un nombre faramineux chez l'adulte
environ cent mille unités interagissent
avec l'animal et elles interagissent
d'une façon un petit peu particulière
c'est qu'elles sont capables de produire
l'énergie qui va nourrir l'animal en
d'autres termes l'animal ne se nourrit
jamais quand il est juvénile
l'animal est translucide il doit trouver
ses partenaires de microalgues voyez ici
s'il nous pour vivre le juvénile de
roscoff encore dans son cocon protecteur
doit ingérer et surtout pas digéré ces
microalgues vous allez me dire ok
comment est ce que je fais pour vivre si
ce que geiger je ne le digère pas eh
bien ce sont les micro algues et qui
sont capables les migrants agde vivante
qui sont capables de réaliser un
processus biologique qui s'appelle la
photosynthèse
j'ouvre une petite parenthèse sur la
photosynthèse on revient sur les bancs
du collège ça c'est un petit peu loin à
la surface de la terre tous les végétaux
qu'ils soient terrestres ou marins y
compris les microalgues sont capables de
réaliser une réaction biochimique
complexe qui intègre à la fois en tout
cas qui réunit à la fois de l'énergie
lumineuse du dioxyde de carbone le co2
atmosphérique ou le co2 dissous dans la
mer de l'eau et des sels minéraux et à
la fin de cette réaction
il y a une production de sucre de
lipides de protéines qui vont aider le
végétal à se développer
4 et bien quand on transpose tout cela à
l'échelle du verre de roscoff vous
comprenez que ce sont les micro algues
qui produisent ces composés nutritifs et
qui en transfère une partie au vert mais
ce n'est pas tout les microalgues ils
sont également capables de d'utiliser et
de recycler les déchets métaboliques du
verre vous voyez cet échange cette
communication de ce transfert constant
permanent entre la ligue et l'animal
c'est ce qu'on appelle une photo
symbiose alors viens pas mal d'auteurs
qui ont dit du verre de roscoff que
c'était une plante animal moi je lui
préfère le surnom d' animal gh any man 2
en 1 et là ça prend tout son sens cet
organisme est bien plus que la somme des
deux partenaires
c'est davantage une association durable
fonctionnelle une relation intime
cette fameuse photo symbiose donc vous
venez de comprendre et de résoudre avec
moi cette équation un plus un égale 1 on
va pas s'arrêter là au laboratoire
on travaille beaucoup sur la
compréhension de ce mode de vie comment
est-ce qu'un animal à un moment donné
devient photosynthétiques comment est-ce
qu'il acquiert cette capacité qu'ont les
plantes d'utiliser l'énergie lumineuse
on s'interroge sur la mise en place de
ce partenariat est pour vous montrer
l'utilité de l'utilité en tout cas
l'importance de la lumière chez cette
espèce
il ya une petite expérience assez
amusante qui consiste à exposer une
culture de roscoff n 6 d'un côté alors
là pour vous c'est votre droite et on a
changé brutalement l'exposition
lumineuse on la vit de l'autre côté
donc ce que vous pouvez observer c'est
une migration brutale de ses verts d'un
côté où fut la lumière de l'autre côté
où elle est réapparue
donc vous comprenez très bien les
animaux vont vers l'énergie lumineuse
là où ils vont trouver cette énergie
pour faire des méthodes des protéines
des lipides les transférer aux eaux au
vert
ne j'espère vous avez pas pris trop
d'importance ou donner trop d'importance
à ceux qui tournent sur eux-mêmes
je m'en doutais en fait vous avez
surtout regarder ça bon je pensais que
vous étiez beaucoup plus sérieux quand
même
on sait pas pourquoi est ce que c'est
pour est ce que c'est pour amuser la
galerie c'est pas possible
en tout cas en tout cas cultivé et puis
héberger des algues dans ses propres
tissus
c'est beaucoup plus sérieux que ça et ça
nécessite quelques adaptations
particulière je vous parlais de 3
prouesse biologique du ver de roscoff
celle de résister au soleil qui sont aux
fortes luminosités au fort rayonnement
solaire
deuxièmement cette capacité à régénérer
son cerveau troisièmement le contrôle de
la prolifération cellulaire
tout à l'heure j'ai oublié de vous dire
que 1 des produits de la photosynthèse
c'est aussi l'oxygène d'accord ce même
oxygène que nous respirons tous et bien
le vert qui passent plusieurs heures au
soleil reçoit du rayonnement solaire
dont du rayonnement ultraviolet mais
également à de l'oxygène qui
s'accumulent dans cette issue la
combinaison de ces deux effets conduit à
ce qu'on appelle le stress oxydatif
chez nous ça peut même aller jusqu'à
déclencher des cancers lorsqu'elle
intéressant avec les verts de roscoff
c'est que lui il n'a pas besoin de crème
solaire anti lgv est et en plus il prend
pas de coup de soleil inspirant non
deuxièmement la régénération du cerveau
vous prenez un verre de roscoff ou
l'anesthésié important et puis vous lui
couper la tête
vous attendez une vingtaine de jours et
au bout de vingt jours on voit une
régénération complète de la partie
manquante à la fois l' enveloppe et à la
fin ce qui est à l'intérieur
le cerveau et toutes ces connexions
neuronales vous imaginez si nous
pouvions avoir cette capacité de
régénération de nos propres tissus
cérébraux
quand ils sont endommagés qu'ils
vieillissent trop vite ou trop tôt
troisième province le contrôle de la
division disons de la prolifération
cellulaire
vous avez vu et vous l'avez compris je
n'en doute pas les micro algues se
divisent intensément et prolifèrent chez
le juvénile jusqu'à envahir tout le
corps de l'animal
et bien tout ça ça mime une
prolifération de cellules tumorales ou
cancéreuse est bien là encore le vert à
déployer un mécanisme qui lui permet de
contrôler cette vague de cellules
proliférant tri proliférante mécanisme
qu' il serait intéressant de comprendre
puisque on arrête on contrôle cette
population on la maintient en vie je
pense qu'elle pourrait inspirer la
médecine voilà vous avez compris ce
petit verre me fait rêver
entre autres et puis puisque on se
connaît un petit peu mieux maintenant je
vais vous parler d'un projet qui me
tient à coeur qui est encore une ébauche
de projet qui concerne une autre utilité
possible du maire de roscoff et qui en
direct connexion avec la conquête
spatiale
dans l' iss qui est un bijou de
technologie le problème est bien c'est
de respirer et de consommer de l'énergie
c'est d'être complètement autonome alors
il ya ça c'est relié par un cordon
ombilical fragile qui est un cargo qui
vient amener tous les trois mois à peu
près ces ressources et de l'eau de
l'oxygène est de la nourriture est de
ramener les déchets pour être recyclés
sur terre si on devait partir en tout
cas sur des voyages au long cours
pendant plusieurs mois ou plusieurs
années dans
dans l'espace emmenés autant de matériel
serait impossible autant de ressources
serait pour l'instant pas possible et
donc il faut imaginer des outils pour
pouvoir produire la ressource à
l'intérieur de liesse et la recycler bon
maintenant que la biologie de du verre
de roscoff a de moins en moins de
secrets je crois vous voyez où je veux
en venir
eh bien le vert de roscoff remplit
toutes les fonctions en tout cas de
grandes fonctions pour imaginer et créer
ce que l'on appelle ou ce qu'on pourrait
appeler un écosystème biotechnologiques
pour produire de l'oxygène
celui que respirent les cosmonautes
recycler le co2 de co2 celui qui est mis
par les cosmonautes recycler une partie
de leurs déchets métaboliques et
pourquoi pas les nourrir avec les micro
algues dont certaines sont comestibles
je ne dis pas que le ver de roscoff et
la solution en tout cas c'est un modèle
d'inspiration important et je pense
intéressant
voilà je vous propose pour terminer de
redescendre sur la plage des verts de
roscoff et je vous parlais de d'une
chose qui me motive particulièrement qui
consiste à transmettre à transférer
on a enseigné à partager ce que je vous
ai présenté ce soir il ya quelques
années j'ai inventé un kit disons un
support pédagogique un outil
d'enseignement et d'éducation de la
biologie marine qu'on a appelé le kit
duverne le kit du verre de roscoff
alors ça permet d'expédier sur les
paillasses des collèges des lycées des
universités françaises ou européennes
le ver de roscoff
avec ou sans ces algues les algues sol
etc l'ensemble de son cycle de
développement de ces étapes de
développement
ce que je j'espère surtout c'est que au
delà de l'expérimentation au delà de la
manipulation de l'observation et même au
delà de l'apprentissage des grands
phénomènes de la biologie photosynthèse
photo symbiose le nombre des micro
algues etc etc
j'espère que des jeunes gens de 20 ans
vous
on comprend pourront comprendre ce que
moi j'ai compris à 50 ans et parfois
avec difficulté
et puis la cerise sur le gâteau je vous
avoue ce serait que les générations
montantes puisse vraiment s'inspirait
pas seulement du verre de roscoff et de
sa biologie mais puisse vraiment
s'inspirer de cet animal pour imaginer
un monde différent pour prendre
conscience qu'il faut prendre soin des
environnements terrestres et marins bref
s'en servir comme modèle alors il se
trouve que tout à l'heure j'ai rencontré
une jeune fille qui s'appelle du cil et
j'aimerais bien comme je suis venu avec
mon animal favori te le confier et puis
pourtant face le meilleur usage que tu
observes que tu le montre à tes parents
et tes copines à des professeurs et que
tu en prennent grand soin et je
t'expliquerai tout à l'heure comment
bien temps d'occuper voilà
[Applaudissements]
voilà je crois que vous avez compris que
le verre de roscoff
au delà de sa couleur verte me donne
beaucoup d'espoir il me donne surtout
envie de viser la lune et comme disait
norman d'un s'empilent combien même on
échoue et combien même on passerait à
côté de la lune on atterrir est quand
même dans les étoiles
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]